ah non je voulais dire on va passer au
gros dossier people c'est un peu ma
grande gueule ma grande gueule et ma
carrière on a Éric Naulleau et Véronique
Genest de de star euh et
qu'effectivement paye un petit peu
aujourd'hui leur grande gueule en tous
les cas c'est ce qu'ils disent on va
essayer d'en débattre avec eux regarde
d'abord ce sujet et puis évidemment on
les reçoit merci encore Thomas
[Musique]
on les connaît pour leur grande gueule
et leur coûte 100 légendaire
Alain Finkielkraut Michel Sardou encore
Jean-Marie Bigard il chante aux ordres
du pognon Jean-Marie vous avez une rage
incroyable si certains les considère
comme des réactionnaires ils ont le
mérite d'assumer pleinement leurs
convictions
est connu pour cette écharpe et
plusieurs fois sur les plateaux télé
notamment lors de ces années on n'est
pas couché aux côtés d'Éric Zemmour
portez des pantalons en lambeaux et une
robe que ça fait de vous un rebelle
aujourd'hui que son côté grande gueule
et son amitié avec le président du parti
reconquête ne l'ont pas aidé dans le
milieu quand même avec ce que j'ai fait
j'ai pas d'émission culturelles s'il y a
quelque chose de bizarre et il n'est pas
le seul à avoir été boycoté par certains
médias comme la crise Véronique jeunesse
depuis ses prises de position sur la
guerre en Ukraine ou vis-à-vis du vaccin
s'est attiré les foudres on rendait
compte des monstruosités que vous avez
dites et vous faites machine arrière
surtout en fait délicat de dévoiler ses
opinions quand on est sous le feu des
projecteurs ce soir Véronique gen avec
de l'eau sont nos invités exceptionnels
Véronique Genest déjà hurl sur le
Magnéton
c'est du grand n'importe quoi voilà
pourquoi parce que j'ai jamais fait
machine arrière sur ce que je dis déjà
déjà
été boycoté par qui que ce soit parce
que pour être il faut déjà avoir quelque
chose à [ __ ]
[Rires]
quand je veux donc franchement je te
trouve que ce magnéto on leur dira c'est
pas moi qui l'ai fait déjà merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous
Eric nolo aussi merci beaucoup Eric
alors du coup qu'est-ce qu'on fait on
commence par ça vous dérange pas
on a 22 minutes
pour savoir qu'on me propose des choses
mais je souvenir qu'il y a un an par
exemple un an ou un an et demi on vous a
proposé sur France Télévisions de
participer à une série de enfin téléfilm
si c'était sur fantasme le téléfilm sur
la GPA de marque ça c'est autre chose
pour me faire taper dessus à la sortie
pour être seul non mais j'avais accepter
de le faire pour les gens c'était donc
un documentaire sur la GPA ici du
bouquin a marqué évidemment on a fait un
bouquin dessus vous deviez soi-disant
jouer un rôle dedans la productrice
m'avait contacté mais moi j'avais rien
signé j'avais contacté et puis après en
télévision a dit non mais vous êtes
d'accord nous avec les tweets combien
vers une jeunesse sur la GPA où vous
étiez contre la GPA finalement la chaîne
Youtube
j'ai été contacté pour faire ce film
j'ai dit non à la base j'ai eu la
metteur en scène au téléphone qui était
une fille formidable la productrice
parce que justement
c'était un rôle de merde c'était la
fille qui est contre la GPA donc
j'allais manger tout le monde à la
sortie
c'est lourdement la transe télévision SS
tu es lourdement jusqu'au moment où
comment il s'appelle déjà
Marco avec qui en plus j'avais fait un
truc effectivement sur la
gparés sur les dérives de la
[Rires]
pour donner le droit aux gens de décider
de ce qu'ils vont faire de leur corps
vous avez comme ça c'est pas moi qui
l'ai écrit ça vous avez quand même
effectivement que le fait que vous
oblige d'être d'activer vous êtes sur
comme un viol parce que je l'ai fait
contre mon gré bien sûr ben vous êtes
cons la troisième dose oui complètement
la troisième je suis contre l'obligation
vaccinale
parce que je pense que c'est non non
c'est contre l'obligation que vous avez
comparer un viol oui bien sûr voilà
toujours un viol un viol littéraire
c'est un viol un violon n'a pas besoin
d'être violée au sens viole du terme
physique et sexuelle il peut avoir un
viol quand on se fait cambrioler c'est
comme un viol aussi donc le viol a quand
même d'autres en colocations là où je
vais en venir Mathieu voilà là vous êtes
morts
là vous êtes non mais là il y aura
aucune coupe et tout ça vous dites ce
que vous voulez Véronique mais c'est
vrai que à chaque fois que vous parlez
c'est quelque part un petit séisme la
dernière fois vous avez parlé de
l'Ukraine en disant voilà on peut être
pro-ukraine pro pro Russie mais on peut
être alors pendant la tronche vous avez
dit je ne suis ni pour Poutine ni pour
Hélène qui en revanche vous vous êtes
clairement contre Poutine en quoi est-ce
une opinion plus tolérable
en tout cas vous avez dit que vous étiez
pas
contredine
un autre et vous êtes ni pour ni l'un ni
compte pour moi il y a l'envahisseur
c'est Poutine c'est c'est clair c'est
net et puis il y a les responsables il y
a la responsabilité de de si vous
regardez le très très beau documentaire
que je vous conseille la longue route
pour la guerre vous comprendrez à quel
moment mettre des noms non mais vous
comprendrez
toutes les guerres ont été voulu alors
que la grande et que leur grande
attitude c'était qui ne peut être
considéré comme je veux pas revenir sur
le fond je veux revenir sur la forme
Véronique juste sur la forme pendant des
années vous avez été l'héroïne de Julie
SCO que j'adorais pour mettre les cordes
et femmes dedans c'était une des
première série pour les gens vous étiez
ça aujourd'hui c'est ça que je veux en
venir aujourd'hui malheureusement quand
on pense à vous d'en penser à vous pour
ces phrases sur Poutine sur le covid sur
la GPA sur les musulmans pour la
dernière pièce que j'ai joué avec Daniel
Russo et qui a plein de gens genre 15
pièces par j'ai lu 15 pièces en 10 jours
là donc il y a pas certainement il y a
beaucoup de gens qui ont envie de
travailler avec moi et qui a pas à la
télévision mais attendez est-ce que moi
j'ai envie de faire la télévision pour
ce qu'on me propose vous avez changé
vous avez cherché le truc
c'est facile le dire aux gens qu'on est
boycoté moi je l'ai boycotte aussi tous
ces gens là moi je ne veux pas
travailler avec des gens qui veulent
absolument que que avoir barre sur vous
vous devez fermer votre gueule pour
faire partie de leur réseau ça ne
m'intéresse pas et ça ne m'a jamais
intéressé depuis que je suis petite moi
je suis contre la doxa et contre le
dogme j'étais dans une école religieuse
on le disait il faut croire ça je disais
ah oui pourquoi parce que moi j'ai
besoin de pourquoi j'ai besoin de
comment oui c'est pourquoi oui la
science d'aujourd'hui c'est un dogme la
science en fait c'est avant tout quelque
chose qu'on conteste on peut échanger
qui évolue ça ne peut pas être un dogme
c'est anticipé
parce que sur sur l'Ukraine et sur
Poutine là j'ai passé un exemple à
magnéto sur les les musulmans mais les
musulmans j'ai rien contre j'ai jamais
regardé contre vous avez dit
et puis après j'aimerais aussi avoir la
vie des réclame vous avez dit il me font
peur regardez l'extrait vous avez dit
Madame et sa Guillaume excuse-moi on a
pas le droit islamophobes c'est d'avoir
peur je suis islamophobe français mais
ça c'est condam Madame
islamophobe sur les mots là vous jouez
sur les mots c'est ce que j'ai laissé
votre vous fracturer la société vous
savez très bien vous savez très bien
peur alors oui effectivement je suis
islamophobe parce que j'ai peur les
propos racistes éradicaux vous n'avez
jamais tenu pourquoi votre collègue en
avant très ça ça fait des années qu'elle
est plus dans la série
pourquoi pour vous renvoyer
mais bien sûr vous vous êtes en train de
me soutenez en direct de l'être mais ça
vous plaisantez ou quoi alors d'abord je
veux faire un maquiller que
sémantiquement islamophobie ça parle de
l'islam et pas des musulmans d'accord
donc effectivement
je n'aime pas les religions et je n'aime
pas l'islam j'ai le droit et vous aviez
ajouté et vous aviez ajouté je parle
évidemment des intégristes pour ceux qui
veulent faire la différence
comme moi je ne l'aime pas je ne l'aime
pas
le marge homosexuel vous n'aimez pas la
GPA vous n'aimez pas les musulmans vous
n'aimez pas le vaccin contre le covid
vous n'aimez rien vous avez été lire que
j'aimais pas le mariage d'homosexuel moi
j'ai jamais été anti Mario j'ai deux
frères homo j'ai deux frères homo borax
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
que chacun
une religion mais moi par exemple je
suis juive vous n'aimez pas la religion
juive vous pouvez dire je n'aime pas la
religion mais pas je n'aime pas un juif
et je déteste
qui est juif homo qui a pas été vacciné
et que vous pensez
j'ai une question ça a toujours été
comme ça cette émission
[Musique]
a changé un peu non non mais moi je suis
ravi de parler avec après Véronique ce
que je vous propose un petit peu c'est
que vous avez tendance un petit peu les
choses j'ai jamais dit ça enfin écoutez
parce que c'est pas grave c'est pas
grave du tout vous êtes libre amenez des
choses où je l'ai dit parce que je vous
jure sur la tête de mon de de mon frère
parce que j'ai plus ma mère j'ai pu
faire ça donc même charrette de mon fils
que j'adore vous verrez bien que je ne
les ai pas dites je ne les ai jamais
dites attention j'adore les mots et je
faisais très attention à ce que je dis
oui alors donc pardon Eric oui vous
voulez dire quelque chose non c'était
une question sur sur l'émission
C'est normal non non le problème n'est
pas encore à vous le problème c'est il y
a beaucoup de choses qu'elle dites
Véronique avec lesquelles je suis pas
d'accord mais je moi je pense qu'on
devrait pouvoir en débat de manière un
peu sereine argument contre argument et
pas ce qu'on a vu par exemple avec
Verdez ou là de toute façon il y a pas
de débat possible parce que celui qui
sera le plus et qui accusera l'autre et
l'autre contre accusera donc ça en plus
comme c'est des thèmes extrêmement
délicat ça tourne mal et on apprend
jamais rien donc là je suis d'accord
avec Véronique on devrait pouvoir
discuter de tout mais pas dans les
conditions et même pas comme vous le
faites Véronique depuis le début ou vous
êtes très véhémente et voilà j'ai même
pas besoin j'ai même pas envie
d'intervenir parce que je sais que voilà
je préférerais que sur certaines choses
que vous avez dites sur l'Islam sur le
reste on puisse en débattre plus
calmement